[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومناطق في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه
البدايه من العاصمه السودانيه وتحذير
الامم المتحده من انتشار الكرا في البلاد
وسط تقارير متزايده عن حالات اسهال مائي
حاد في كل من الخرطوم وجنوب
كردفان الى واشنطن التي تعيش على وقع
مداولات متسارعه في الكونغرس الامريكي
بمجلسيه لتجنب اغلاق حكومي بعد يوم واحد
ما لم يتم التوصل الى اتفاق بشان
الميزانيه والى الحدود الامريكيه
المكسيكيه وعبور 50 الف طالب لجوء من دول
امريكا اللاتينيه نهر ريو جراندي خلال
الاسبوع الحالي والسلطات الامريكيه تتوقع
المزيد وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه
الليله يوم دام في باكستان عشرات القتل
والجرحى في هجومين انتحاريين احدهما
استهدف حشدا احتفاليا بمناسبه المولد
النبوي الشريف واخر استهدف مصلين قرب
بشاور مع نزوح اكثر من 100 الف من ارمن
كارباخ الى ارمينيا الامم المتحده تعلن
ارسال بعثه انسانيه الى الاقليم للمره
الاولى منذ 30 عاما شرطه اذربيجان تنتشر
في كارباخ وموسكو تقول انها ستناقش مع
باكو مستقبل قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه
هجمات جديده بالمسيرات تستهدف العمق
الروسي بالتزامن مع معارك شرقيه وجنوبيه
اوكرانيا بوتين يطلب من مساعد سابق ل
بريغوجين الاشراف على متطوعين للقتال في
اوكرانيا والكرملين يعلن توقيع 350 الف
مقاتل عقودا مع وزاره
الدفاع في احدث حلقات التازم بين الرئيس
سعيد والمعارضه بتونس راشد الغنوشي يبدا
اضرابا عن الطعام تضامنا مع القيادي بجبهه
الخلاص المعتقل جوهر بن مبارك والشاب يدعو
الى حشد الجهود للتصدي لاحتكار السلطه
والحكم
التعسفي في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم دخول
رموز من المعارضه التونسيه في اضراب عن
الطعام احتجاجا على ما وصفته هيئه الدفاع
عن السجناء السياسيين بفضيحه قضائيه
يقودها قاضي التحقيق عبر ملفات ملفقه ضد
معارضي الرئيس قيس سعيد لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي والسؤال يقول في رايكم الى اين
تتجه الازمه بالنظر لتعاطي السلطات مع ملف
المعتقلين السياسيين النتائج جاءت كالتالي
51% توقعوا المزيد من التازم والانسداد
بين الرئيس سعيد ومعارضيه بينما رجح 88%
فقط امكانيه التراجع الرئاسه والسلطات
التونسيه عن هذه الاجراءات المشدده في حين
راى
41% ان المشهد لن يتغير في البلاد وان
السجال بين الرئاسه
ومعارضيها سيستمر على حاله هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه لقاء على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
وقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا وتتابعون في الحصاد
ايضا الولايات المتحده على شفا اغلاق
حكومي دون بوادر لاي اتفاق
[موسيقى]
لتفاديه
اهلا بكم هجومان داميان يضربان باكستان
اليوم 57 قتيلا على الاقل وعشرات الجرحى
في تفجيرين استهدف على نحو لافت مسجدين في
اقليمين منفصلين وبينما توعدت السلطات من
وصفتها بالجماعات الارهابيه والجهات التي
تمولها وتدربها لم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها
حتى
اللحظه
حداد لثلاثه ايام في بلوشستان جنوب غربي
باكستان من تكبيرات واناشيد دينيه الى
صراخات الاستغاثه لانقاذ الجرحى وانتشال
جثث القتلى انهى تفجير انتحاري وهو ليس
الوحيد في البلاد الاحتفالات بالمولد
النبوي الشريف بمشاهد مرعبه قتل فيها
العشرات واصيب عدد كبير بجروح خرجت
المواكب من عده مساجد لتلتقي عند نقطه
تجمع فرقهم فيها دوي الانفجار الذي وقع
بالقرب من سياره للشرطه عند مسجد وفق
روايه شهود عيان اكتظت مستشفيات ماستون
بالضحايا ووصفت اصابات العديد من الجرحى
بالخطير كان الجهه التي تقف وراء هذه
الهجمات كانت مصره على اطاله فاجعه
الباكستانيين اذ وقع انفجاران اخر احدهما
عند بوابه المسجد والاخر في صحنه في اقليم
خيبر تخوا بولايه بشاور قتل ما لا يقل عن
اربعه اشخاص في حصيله اعلنتها الشرطه كان
العدد سيكون اكبر لو لم يحدث اشتباك بين
قوات الامن ومسلحين يحملان رشاشات اليه
وقنابل يدويه وسترات ناسفه حاول اختراق
التدابير الامنيه حصر تحت انقاض سقف
المسجد الذي وقع من شده التفجير ما لا يقل
عن 30 مصليا لم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن
التفج في مناطق لها تاريخ في نشاط
الجماعات المسلحه المتشدده والانفصال ايضا
اول رد فعل رسمي كان من وزير الداخليه
الباكستاني في الحكومه المؤقته قال ان
بلاده لن تدخر جهدا من اجل القضاء على
الارهابيين والجهات التي تعمل على تمويلهم
وتجهيزهم استهدفوا المواطنين الذين كانوا
يحتفلون بمولد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
اكد لكم ان الدوله تقف الى جانب المظلومين
وستبذل كل ما في وسعها لدحر هؤلاء
المجرمين وقواتنا المسلحه لديها القدره
على تتبع الارهابيين وتوجيه ضربات ضد
الجهات التي تمولهم وتدربهم اينما
كانت سبق ان عاشت باكستان تفجيرات مماثله
خلال نفس المناسبه الدينيه قتل انتحاري في
ابريل 2006 50 شخصا على الاقل في مدينه
كراتشي الساحليه عندما فجر نفسه وسط موكب
المحتفلين تحبس باكستان انفاسها كل ما
اقترب موعد الانتخابات المقرره في يناير
المقبل يعاني البلد من ازمه سياسيه وشلل
اقتصادي وتصعيد في الهجمات المسلحه اما
بتوقيع طالبان باكستان او تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ولايه خرسان كانت جمعه داميه
مواكب المحتفلين بمولد خاتم الانبياء
والمرسلين ح حولها الانتحاريون الى مواكب
جنازات معنا من اسلام اباد مراسلنا سمير
نمري اهلا بك سمير ما اخر تفاعلات الحدثين
الدامي لهذا
اليوم نعم محمد بالفعل باكستان عاشت يوما
صعبا ويوما مؤلما فمع ساعات الصباح الاولى
من يوم الجمعه كان هناك عطله رسميه عنتها
الحكومه الباكستانيه بمنا مناسبه المولد
النبوي الشريف عندما باغت انتحاري جموع من
المحتفلين في منطقه موستن في في اقليم
بلوشستان
عندما باغت هؤلاء الحشود وقام بتفجير نفسه
بالقرب من سياره الشرطه وقتل وقتل في ذلك
التفجير اكثر من نحو 53 شخصا واصيب
العشرات من بين القتلى نائب مفوض الشرطه
في المنطقه بعد ذلك بساعات كان انتحاريان
على متني سياره يريدان اقتحام احد مراكز
الشرطه في مدينه هونجو
باقليم خيبر المتاخم للحدود الافغانيه و
تصدت الشرطه لهؤلاء المهاجمين فبينما قتلت
احدهما تمكن الاخر من التسلل الى داخل
مركز الشرطه حيث كانت صلاه جمعه في مسجد
مركز الشرطه قائمه ففجر نفسه في المصلين
بحسب بيان الشرطه قتل في ذلك الانفجار
خمسه اشخاص واصيب نحو 12 اخرين عندما تحطم
وانهار سقف المنز المسجد على المصلين ولم
تعرف بعد الحصيله النهائيه ل لهؤلاء
الضحايا او لهذا التفجير كانت شرطه
باكستان في عموم الاقاليم قد استنفرت يوم
امس الجمعه في كل الاقاليم لان مناسبه
احتفال المولد النبوي الشريف تزامنت مع
يوم الجمعه حيث تحتشد الاف المصلين في
جميع المصليات وجميع المساجد هنا في
العاصمه اسلام اباد كانت الشرطه قد اصدرت
بيان واكدت انها اعلنت حاله الاستنفار
القصوى شرطه البنجاب القريبه من هنا ايضا
نشرت اكثر من
46000 شرطي في عموم الاقليم لا سما بعد
صلاه الجمعه في محاوله لمنع اي حدوث اي
اختراق امني يسعى ما سمته الشرطه المخربون
او
الارهابيون لتنفيذه واستغلال هذه هذا
الزخم الديني للاحتفال به كان هناك ايضا
ردود رسميه نددت بهذين التفجيرين حيث اكد
رئيس الجمهوريه على ضروره ضه محاسبه
الفاعلين بينما طالب رئيس الوزراء المؤقت
انوار الحق كاكار بضروره الوقوف والتصدي
بحزم لما سماه الارهاب هناك ايضا تشهد هذه
الاقليم وهما اقليم بلوشستان واقليم خيبر
حاله من التفجيرات وايضا شهد عدد من
الاختراقات الامنيه في الاشهر الماضيه
وكانت هذه الاحداث تشهد تصاعدا لا فتن لا
سما مع اقتراب الانتخابات المقرر عقدها في
في يناير الماضي وهو ما
سيلقي مجمل الصعوبات على تلك الانتخابات
شكرا جزيلا لك سمير نمري من اسلام اباد
ينضموا الينا الان من اسلام اباد الخبير
والمحلل الامني اسد محمود اهلا بكم سيد
محمود ما ابرز ما يمكن استخلاصه مما جرى
اليوم
في البدايه نحن نتحدث عن يوم حزين في كل
ارجاء البلاد وكما اشرتم جرى الحدثان في
ساعات الصباح الاولى
وهناك اشخاص كانوا من المصلين يحتفلون
بالمولد النبوي الشريف وهذا ايضا الهجوم
الثاني هناك هجوم ثاني استهدف المسجد
الثاني في مركز الشرطه وادى ذلك ايضا الى
مقتل خمسه اشخاص هذه الانشطه الارهابيه
وبكل
تاكيد تتم او السؤال هو بنيابه عما اذا
هناك حركه طالبان باكستان وتنظيم الدوله
ولايه خراسان وهناك تنظيمات اخرى تعمل في
المنطقه من افغانستان على سبيل المثال
و انا متاكد من ان وكالات انفاذ القانون
الباكستانيه لديها قلق ازاء هذا الموضوع
وتلك الانشطه الارهابيه وارسلت رساله جاده
للغايه مؤخرا لافان
بان افغانستان يجب ان لا تستخدم ابدا من
قبل حركه طالبان باكستان او داعش للهجوم
على باكستان هذا يوم حزين بالنسبه الينا
في باكستان هذه الانشطه الارهابيه من قبل
المجمعات او المجموعات الارهابيه تتزايد
ولكنني متاكد من ان وكالات انفاذ القانون
والوكالات
الاستخباريه ف تعمل على تحديد المسؤولين
ومواجهه هذه المشكله وهذا ما وعدت به
وتوعدت ماذا عساها تفعل هذه الجهات
الامنيه بكل تاكيد وكالات انفاذ القانون
والوكالات الاستخباريه سوف تنشر اعداد
متزايده من العديد بالاضافه الى تحسين
التنسيق والتعاون بين الوكالات
الاستخباريه وفي الوقت نفسه
اتاحه
القوات الامنيه
للتصرف
وتنسيق مع الوكالات المدنيه والادارات
المدنيه اذا هناك ضروره لنشر هذه القوات
لكي يعرف الجميع ان هناك جديه في التعاطي
ب الموضوع وهذا هو الرد على الارهابيين
وسوف يتم القضاء على الارهابيين اينما وجد
هذه هي الرساله التي سوف تصل في الايام
المقبله انت اشرت الى بعض الجهات التي
ترجح انها جاءت من من افغانستان ولكن لحد
الان لم يتبنى اي طرف ما جرى ما تفسيرك
لذلك
بكل تاكيد صحيح ولكن بكل تاكيد الوكالات
الامنيه الباكستانيه والوكالات
الاستخباريه
الباكستانيه لديها ادله بان الاراضي
الافغانستانيه قد استخدمت في السابق
وتستخدم لشن العمليات الارهابيه وهذه
المجموعات تنشط وتعمل في الداخل الافغاني
بحريه وان
الحكومه الطالبان في افغانستان لديها
مشاكل حقيقيه مع تنظيم داعش وايضا يمكننا
ان نرى ان
الرد لم يتم كما كان متوقعا من قبل
الحكومه الباكستانيه وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الحكومه الافغانيه يجب ان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بجديه كي لا تسوء
تلك المنقه وخصوصا على الحدود مع
افغانستان شكرا لك اسد محمود من اسلام
[موسيقى]
اباد قال المفوض السامي للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ان اكثر من 100 ال من ارمن
كارباخ نزحوا الى ارمينيا وقد اعلنت الامم
المتحده ان بعثه لتقييم الاحتياجات
الانسانيه ستصل الى اقليم كارباخ بنهايه
هذا الاسبوع وذلك في خطوه هي الاولى من
نوعها منذ نحو ثلاثه عقود ونقل مراسل
الجزيره عن مصادر محليه قولها ان شرطه
الاذربيجانيه بدات الانتشار في ستيبن كيرت
عاصمه الاقليم واظهرت صور انتشار الشرطه
الاذربيجانيه في شوارع
العاصمه في غدون ذلك اعلنت اداره امن
الحدود الاذربيجانيه اعتقال اليوفا
مسكان التي شغلت منصب وزيره الدفاع فيما
كان يعرف بحكومه جمهوريه كارباخ وذلك بين
عامي 2015
و2018 وقالت الاداره في بيان ان عمليه
الاعتقال جرت عند النقطه الحدوديه في معبر
لاتشين اثناء محاولتها العبور نحو ارمينيا
كما ذكر جهاز الامن امن الدوله في
اذربيجان انه اعتقل ديفيد مانوكيان النائب
الاول لقائد ما يعرف بجيش كارباخ خلال
محاولته عبور المعبر ذاته الى ارمينيا
ووجهت لمانو كيان تهم عده ابرزها دعم
الارهاب واداره مجموعات مسلحه وتزويدها
بالاسلحه والمتفجرات على الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه وفي ريفيان قال وزير الدفاع
الارميني ان الباب مفتوح امام عناصر ما
كان يعرف بجيش كارباخ للانضمام للجيش
الارمني من جهه ثانيه افادت السلطات
الارمنيه ان عدد النازحين من اقليم كارباخ
الى ارمينيا ارتفع الى نحو
90,000 وقالت المتحدثه باسم رئيس الوزراء
الارماني انه تم تامين سكن مؤقت لنحو 20
ال و300 من هؤلاء
النازحين هذا وقد قال الكريملين ان مساله
ابرام معاهده السلام بين ارمينيا
واذربيجان ما تزال ذات اهميه واضاف
الكريملين ان موسكو ستناقش مع باكو مستقبل
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه الموجوده على
اراضي
اذربيجان ومن جانب اخر بحث رئيس البرلمان
الارميني الين سيمونيان ونظيره الاوكراني
روسلان ستيف تشوك في العاصمه الايرلنديه
دبلن ناقشا الاوضاع في اقليم كارباخ ونزوح
السكان الارمن منه وقالت وسائل اعلام
ارمنيه ان اللقاء جاء على هامش اجتماع
لممثلي برلمانات دول مجلس اوروبا واشارت
الى ان المسؤول الاوكراني اكد على اهميه
التعاون بين كيف
وفيان ينضم الينا الان من مدينه باث
البريطانيه الدكتور ستيفن هول الاكاديمي
المتخصص في شؤون منطقه القوقاز اهلا وسهلا
بك ان ترسل الامم المتحده بعثه انسانيه لا
اقليم كارباخ لاول مره منذ 30 عاما ما
دلاله
ذلك
اعتقد انه بكل
تاكيد هناك احتمال بان القوات
الاذربيجانيه هاجمت المدنيين الارمن في
كارباخ ولكن طبعا هذه مزاعم يجب التحقق
منها هناك ازمه وكارثه انسانيه وهذا ما
تحاول ان تستقصي بشانه الامم المتحده
ضروره التصرف وكيفيه العمل في ذاك الاقليم
هذا النزوح المكثف للمدنيين هل يعني بان
بقائهم في الاقليم مستحيل تقريبا
الان بكل تاكيد يمكنني ان اقول انه لان
الطرفين يمضيان الوقت على البروباجندا
وهناك هجوم من قبل الطرف على الطرف الاخر
دائما هناك صعوبه كبيره للارمن لكي يبقوا
في كارباخ وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن تحديات
اساسيه لاي ارمن يودون ان يبقوا في كارباخ
خصوصا بعد هذه التهديدات هل هل بعثت الامم
المتحده من صلاحياتها ان تتاكد ما اذا كان
هناك تطهير عرقي كما تتهم ارمينيا ام ان
الموضوع هو في الحقيقه
مبادره شخصيه طوعيه من هؤلاء
النازحين اعتقد ان بعثه الامم المتحده ليس
لديها
الاختصاص لكي تقول لباكو ان هناك تطهيرا
عرقيا حصل على الارجح سوف ترفع التقارير
للامم المتحده واذا ما حصل التطهير العرقي
هذا امر يمكن ان يكون قد حصل ولكن طبعا
البعثه ليس باستطاعتها ان تخاطب باكو بشكل
مباشر ان الدول الغربيه كان لديها رسائل
دبلوماسيه عبرت عن صدمتها ازاء ما حصل
ولكنها توقفت عند هذا الحد اذا تواصلت هذه
الوتيره من النزوح هل يخشى ان نجد
اذربيجان في النهايه بلا ارمن على الاطلاق
اعتقد ان هذا الامر قد يحصل ولكن قد يبقى
بعض الناس الارمن الذين ينظرون الى ذاك
المكان على
انه البلد الخاص بهم يفضلون ان يبقوا في
ذاك الاقليم ولكننا وبوضوح وجدنا ان
الاغلبيه الساحقه من ارمن كارباخ قرروا ان
يغادروا باتجاه ارمينيا وعلى الاقل ان
ارمن ناجورنو كارباخ في المرحله الراهنه
ينزحون بشكل داخلي من ضمن ارمينيا هذا
المشكل تقريبا عمره قرن هل يمكن القول
الان انه انتهى
بالكامل د انه يمكننا ان نقول اننا شاهدنا
عددا من الارمن وقد غادروا كارباخ باتجاه
ارمينيا وبناء على ما قالته ارمينيا يمكن
ان نقول ان الحرب قد انتهت لان اذربيجان
هزمت الجيش المحلي في اقل من يوم اذا لم
يتمكنوا من المقاومه وبالتالي النزاع قد
انتهى النزاع كما عرفناه قد انتهى وحكومه
كارباخ تحدثت عن تاريخ يناير 2024 ناغورنو
كارباخ كادار لن تكون موجوده بعد شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد ستيفن
هول نعت قوه دفاع البحرين احد افرادها
برتبه ملازم اول توفي اليوم متاثرا بجراح
كان اصيب بها يوم الاثنين الماضي في هجوم
للحوثيين على الحدود الجنوبيه الجنوبيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبذلك يرتفع عدد
القتلى في هذا الهجوم الى اربعه عسكريين
بحرينيين هذا وقد دان مجلس الامن الدولي
ما وصفه بالهجوم الفضيع المنسوب للحوثيين
باستعمال المسيرات على افراد من القوات
المسلحه البحرينيه العامله ضمن التحالف
العربي لدعم الشرعيه في اليمن واعتبره
عملا تصعيدي وقال المجلس في بيان صحفي
اعتمده اليوم ان الهجوم يشكل تهديدا خطيرا
لعمليه السلام والاستقرار الاقليمي بما في
ذلك في اليمن ودعى الحوثيين الى انهاء
جميع الهجمات الارهابيه وجدد المجلس
الاعراب عن قلقه ااء استهداف البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في المدن الواقعه على
الحدود الجنوبيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودعى مجلس الامن كل الاطراف الى احترام
التزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي بما في
ذلك القانون الدولي
الانساني
[موسيقى]
الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ طلب
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من قائد
اركان فاجنر السابق اندريه تروشي الاشراف
على تشكيل وحدات تطوعيه يمكنها اداء مهام
قتاليه متعدده خصوصا فيما تسميها موسكو
منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ياتي هذا
في وقت تواصل فيه روسيا حشد المزيد من
القوات للقتال في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت في
وقت سابق تقدم نحو
350 الف متطوعا للقتال تحت امره وزاره
الدفاع
الروسيه يقف الرئيس الروسي دقيقه صمت على
ارواح متطوعين قتلوا في حرب اوكرانيا يشيد
بوتين بالاف من السجناء الجنائيين قاتلوا
في اوكرانيا نظير وعود باطلاق سراحهم يقول
ان هؤلاء سددوا دينهم للمجتمع يدشن بوتين
مرحله ما بعد يجين بريغوجين فلم يعد اسم
فاجنر يتردد في الكرملين ولا في اروقه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تستعيد موسكو عنه
بما تسميها كتائب المتطوعين وهم ممن
يتطوعون للقتال في اوكرانيا ولكن شرط ان
يدينوا بالولاء لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه يضع
بوتين امر عشرات الاف المتطوعين بين يدي
ان تشيف او ما يعرف بسيدو الاشيب وهو احد
القاده السابقين في فاجنر ويوصف بانه كان
حلقه الوصل بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه سيقود تروش جزءا من
350 الف مقاتل تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
منذ بدايه العام في الحدي والعش من سبتمبر
من العام الماضي اعلن الرئيس الروسي تعبئه
عسكريه جزئيه للدفاع عن الاراضي الروسيه
كانت هذه التعبئه العسكريه الاولى في
روسيا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفقا
لهذا المرسوم استدعي نحو 300 الف من جنود
الاحتياط وهم جزء من نحو 25 مليونا هم
اجمالي قوه الاحتياط لدى روسيا وهم جميع
المواطنين الذين ادوا الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه وقد امر بوتين انذاك بان تشمل
تعبئه السجناء ممن ادينوا بارتكاب جرائم
خطيره فمنذ بدء الحرب في في اوكرانيا جندت
مجموعه فاغنر ومثلها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عشرات الاف المعتقلين في السجون الروسيه
مقابل وعود بالافراج عنهم لكن زج بهم في
جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا بعد نحو عام على
قرار بوتين على التعبئه يكشف الكرملين عن
قوه عسكريه ثانيه قوامها نحو 350 ال شخص
وقعوا جميعا عقودا مع وزاره الدفاع منذ
بدايه العام الحالي للقتال في اوكرانيا
الحد الادنى للاجر الشهري الذي يعرض على
الجنود المتعاقدين نحو 2700 دولار وهو ما
يقرب من ثلاثه اضعاف متوسط الاجور في
روسيا الى جانب ذلك استدعت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اخيرا 130 الف شخص ممن يستوفون
متطلبات قانون الخدمه العسكريه فيما يعرف
بتجنيد
الخريف تحشد روسيا وتعيد ترتيب صفوف في
قواتها ما يشي بجوله جديده من القتال في
اوكرانيا اكثر شراسه فمقابل التحشيد
الروسي تتوالى شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه على
كيف تدخل دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه الى
ساحه المعارك لتضاف الى نظيرتها الالمانيه
ليبرد وهي بعض من 31 دبابه وعدت الولايات
المتحده في يناير الماضي بتسليمها للجيش
الاوكراني ومن المتوقع ان تتسلم كيف ايضا
خلال ايام صواريخ اكمس ارض ارض وهي صواريخ
بالستيه بعيده المدى موجهه وشديده الدقه
يصل مداها الى نحو 300
م وفي التطورات الميدانيه للحرب اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجوم اوكراني
وتدمير 11 طائره مسيره في اجواء مقاطعتي
كالوجا وكورس الروسيتين خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولم تذكر وزاره الدفاع تفاصيل
بشان خسائر ماديه نتيجه نجه هذا الهجوم
وعلى الجانب الاوكراني اعلن الجيش سقوط
ثلاثه قتلى وخمسه جرحى في قصف الروسي
استهدف مدينه خيرسون جنوبي البلاد واضاف
ان هجمات روسيه استهدفت 140 بلده خلال
الساعات ال والعش الماضيه في
مقاطعات تشير تشيف وسومي
وخاركوف ودونيتسك وزبرو جيا وخرس واشار
الجيش الى ان خاض اكثر من 20 اشتباكا مع
القوات
الروسيه ينضم الينا الان من جنيف العقيد
الكسندر فوتر رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد فوتر في ضوء
اللقاء بوتين بدريه تشيف هل نحن امام
فاجنر ثانيه
ستولد
فاغنر كانت لطالما كانت هيكليه متطوره
وتتغير استحدثت بشكل اساسي للعمل الخارجي
خارج الحدود الروسيه لكي تقول الحكومه
الروسيه انها غير مسؤوله عن العمليات التي
تشارك فيها فاغنر اليوم نحن نرى الحاجه
الملحه الى فاغنر للقتال في هذه الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا ومساله ان تقول الحكومه الروسيه
انها غير مسؤوله لم تعد مطروحه لان نتحدث
عن اشراف مباشر من قبل وزاره الدفاع اذا
في هذه الحاله اذا كان التشكيل الجديد
سيكون بنفس مواصفات التشكيل القديم فاجنر
ما الداعي له
برايك الداعي له هو الحاجه الى حشد مئات
الالاف وكما اشرتم في تقريركم مئات الالاف
من المجندين الجدد في الجيش الروسي وهي
نقطه اساسيه اولا القوات الروسيه ليس
لديها القدرات او المعدات او ما يكفي من
مدربين او من ضباط كبار
للقيام بهذه التدريبات وتحسين الاداء
وتنظيم هذه الهيكليات جديده وبالتالي
الجيش
الروسي حشد اعداد متزايده من المجندين
ويرسل اعدادا متزايده من العديد باتجاه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن جوده القتال
تتراجع ولذلك روسيا بحاجه الى فاجنر هل
معنى ذلك ان الجيش الروسي انهك فعلا في
هذه
الحرب
انهيك
بعض
الوحدات توقفت عن العمل وهناك تدوير
لوحدات اخرى اذا السؤال الاساسي هو
بالنسبه الى القوات الجديده التي اتت
لتستبدل القوات
القديمه السؤال بالنسبه الى هذه الوحدات
اذا هناك وحدات محترفه انخرطت في بدايه
هذه الحرب ومعظم هذه التنظيمات والوحدات
الجديده تفتقر الى التدريب وتفتقر الى
المعدات المماثله لكي تقوم بعمليات هجوميه
ناجعه وفعاله باستطاعتها ان تصد الهجمات
المضاده وتبقى في الخطوط الاماميه ولكن
بالنسبه الى عمليه هجوميه ناجعه وفعاله
موسكو بحاجه الى وحدات محترفه وق قادره
ومدربه واعداد كبيره من هؤلاء هم من
المرتزقه الذين يدفع لهم اجور مرتفعه اكثر
بكثير وفقا لهذه العقود شكرا جزيلا لك
العقيد الكسندر فوترا فير من
[موسيقى]
جنيف قالت حركه النهضه التونسيه ان رئيسها
راشد الغنوشي بدا اضرابا عن الطعام لمده
ثلاث ايام متتاليه دفاعا عن مطلب كل
المعتقلين السياسيين بضروره اطلاق سراحهم
واضافت ان الغنوشي دخل الاضراب تضامنا مع
القيادي بجبهه الخلاص جوهر بن مبارك
المضرب عن الطعام منذ الثلاثاء الماضي من
جهتها دعت جبهه الخلاص المعارضه الى تعديل
موازين القوى لدفع السلطه للتراجع عن ما
وصفتها باجراءات
الغاشمه منعطف جديد تدخله الازمه بين
الرئيس سعيد ومعارضيه في تونس التي تشهد
منذ فبراير الماضي حمله توقيفات شملت
اعلاميين ونشطاء وقضاه ورجال اعمال
وسياسيين يتهم سعيد المعتقلين بالتامر على
امن الدوله والتخابر مع دبلوماسيين غربيين
والفساد المالي ويصفهم بالارهابيين والخوه
بينما تتهمه المعارضه باستخدام القضاء
لملاحقتهم والاصرار على ابعادهم بموجب
ملفات تصفها بالفاره ولا تستند على اي
دلائل او قراءن تدين المعتقلين او تبرر
اعتقالهم ورغم ذلك يتم رفض الافراج عنهم
دون وجه قانوني في جديد المواجهه يتواصل
اضراب الجوع في تونس رئيس حركه النهضه
راشد الغنوشي المعتقل دخل الجمعه في اضراب
عن الطعام مدته ثلاثه ايام
لكن الخطوه في جوهرها تاتي ضمن المطالب
المتصاعده باطلاق سراح جميع المعتقلين
السياسيين على خلفيه الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه التي يفرضها الرئيس سعيد منذ
يوليو عام
2021 جبهه الخلاص المعارضه دعت لتعديل
موازين القوى لدفع السلطه للتراجع عن
اجراءاتها وستنفذ حسب رئيسها احمد نجيب
الشابي مع بدايه الاسبوع المقبل فعاليات
تضامنيه مع جوهر بن مبارك تعبر عن
الاحتجاج على ما اعتبرته مهزله قضائيه
ومظلمه تستهدف جميع التونسيين السلطه لا
تستهدف السياسيين وحدهم بل تستهدف
الاعلاميين
والمدونين
والفنانين
وتستهدف
النقابيين وتستهدف رجال الاعمال وتست تهدف
المسؤولين في المؤسسات العموميه وتستهدف
عشرات الالاف من الموظفين الثابت ان تونس
تسير منذ اجراءات ال من يوليو عام
2021 في خطين متوازيين الرئيس قيس سعيد
وبعد تكريس سلطاته في دستور اقر العام
الماضي خلال استفتاء شهد مقاطعه سياسيه
وشعبيه يصف اجراءاته بانها ضروريه لانقاذ
تونس من الفوضى بينما يرى معارضوه في تلك
الاجراءات ومن بنى عليها من قرارات
احتكارا للسلطه وانهيار للحريات بعد تفكيك
المؤسسات وتمزيق الدستور
السابق وينضم الينا من تونس رياض الشعيبي
عضو جبهه الخلاص الوطني والمستشار السياسي
لرئيس حركه النهضه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
شعيبي دخول ر الغنوشي في هذا الاضراب عن
الطعام ما الذي يامل
منه دخول الاستاذ رشد الغنوشي في اضراب عن
الطعام بدايه من صباح اليوم هو لزياده
الضغط على السلطه من اجل ان تتوقف عن
استهداف الناشطين السياسيين وا الاستمرار
في اعتقال العشرات منهم والتسريع باطلاق
سراحهم وفتح ابواب الحوار لايجاد حل
للازمه التي تمر بها البلاد هذا هو الهدف
الرئيسي لهذا
الاضراب زياده الضغط هذا الذي تشير اليه
اتضح في السابق بانه لا قيمه له ولا
اعتبار له في نظر السلطه اذا ما
الجديد ربما بعض المرادين يعتقدون ان هذه
السلطه لا تخضع للضغط الذي يسلط عليها لكن
تجاربنا العديده معها اثبتت انها في بعض
الاحيان تستجيب لبعض الضغوطات لان انه
القضيه او القضايا المنشوره اليوم امام
المحاكم فيما يتعلق بالمعتقلين السياسيين
وعلى ابتداد اشهر طويله لم تتحرك ولم
يستجد فيها اي مستجد فضلا عن انه هذه
القضايا هي قضايا مفبركه وليس لها اي اساس
واقعي او مادي لذلك اليوم ياتي اضراب
الجوع الذي اعلنه الاستاذ جوهر بنبارك وهو
اضراب جوع مفتوح واضراب الجوع التضامني
الذي اعلن عنه الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي
والاضرابات التي سيقع الاعلان عنها خلال
الايام القادمه والاعتصامات كلها في هذا
السياق نحن نبذل ما في جهدنا من اجل
الدفاع عن المسار الديمقراطي وعن مكتسبات
الشعب التونسي طوال السنوات الماضيه
وا الوصول الان الى حد الاذرا الجوع هو
ذهاب للشكل الاقصى للنضال المدني السلمي
بان يجعل الانسان جسمه و جسده وصحته
وحياته يراهن بها من اجل الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه وهذا ما يفعله المضربون اليوم
اضراب الغنوشي مثل ما ذكرت جاء بعد اضراب
جوهر بن مبارك هل هل هل سيمتد هذا الشكل
النضالي كما تصفه الى البقيه من المعتقلين
وعددهم بالعشرات
تقريبا نعم هذا هو ما سيحصل خلال الاسابيع
والايام القادمه هو ان هذا اضراب الجوع
سيتمدد وسيتو سع وسيشمل تقريبا كل
المعتقلين السياسيين الذين يتجاوز عددهم
الى حد الان ال 40 معتقل سياسي فضلا على
الاضرابات التضامنيه التي ستحصل ايضا داخل
البلاد وخارجها والاعتصامات التي ستقوم
بها المعارضه وستقوم بها ايضا اهالي
المعتقلين اذا هي سلسله من التحركات التي
ستحصل خلال الايام القادمه للتعبير عن
التضامن مع المعتقلين السياسيين وللمطالبة
هي نقطه البدايه لهذه التحركات التي
ستشهدها الب على ذكر هذه الوقفه
والفعاليات التضامنيه التي دعا اليها
السيد احمد نجيب
الشابي الوقفات الماضيه بدت خجوله من حيث
الحضور هل تتوقعون ان ان يكون حجم الحضور
افضل في في الفترات المقبله في الاسابيع
المقبله هي هذه الوقفات الاسبوعيه الان
امتدت لاشهر طويله و منذ البدايه كانت
فلسفه هذه الوقفات انها وقفات رمزيه وليست
وقفات تحشيد
ووقفات وطنيه طبعا بين كل اسبوع تحصل هذه
الوقفه ولكن بين الحين والاخر ننظم وقفه
وطنيه ومسيره وطنيه او مظاهره وطنيه وقد
حضر فيها الالاف في المرات العديده التي
وقع تنظيمها فييه اكثر من 30 تحرك وطني
حصل في تونس سواء في شكل سيره او في ش في
شكل وقفات هذه تحركات وطنيه هذا شكل من
اشكال التحرك ولكن ايضا عندنا وقفات
اسبوعيه هذه الوقفات الاسبوعيه كما قلت هي
وقفات رمزيه للدفاع خصيصا على المعتقلين
السياسيين ولذلك الحضور ليس مطلوبا الحضور
كبير ولكن المطلوب فقط هو التذكير بهذه
القضيه والتمسك بحق هؤلاء المعتقلين في
استعاده حريت شكرا جزيلا لك رياض الشعيبي
من تونس وينضم الينا الان من سوس شرقي
البلاد قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث
القانوني اهلا وسهلا بك سيد صياح الم تكن
السلطه في غنا عن كل هذه الضجه لو تعاملت
بشكل افضل مع هذه
القضيه شكرا مساء الخير السلطه تتعامل منذ
البدايه بالشكل القانوني والشكل التشريعي
الذي يتناسب مع الوضع السياسي للبلاد
والذي تمر فيه تونس في مرحله سياسيه
واجتماعيه واقتصاديه صعبه جدا جدا جدا
ويضاف اليها بطبيعه الحال المناورات
سياسيه الاحزاب المعارضه من الاقليات
الاوليغارش التي تتولى من حين الى اخر
يعني بعصره الاوراق ولم تحاول قط البحث عن
الحوار الجدي ولملمت الامور وبقيت في حرب
الاستنزاف مع السلطه القائمه الى حين
بلغنا هذا الامر الذي بطبيعه الحال لا
يرضاه احد ولا يتمناه احد كل ما في الامر
ان المعارضه لم تلم شملها لم تقم بتوحيد
صفوفها لم تقم بعرض برنامج سياسي واقتصادي
قادر على اخراج الشارع و تغيير اي وضع تر
المعارضه انها قادره للحكم فيه عوضا عن
الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي يحارب الفساد منذ
سنتين تقريبا ويغير نمط وجغرافيا السياسه
في تونس له ممكن زلات له ممكن هينات لكل
رؤساء العالم بما فيها الدول المتقدمه
ولكن رئيس الدوله كان شجاعا وكان قادرا
على تغيير على الاقل تغيير قانون لعبه
الشرنج السياسيه على مستوى الركح السياسي
الحالي بالبلاد
التونسيه اشر اشرت سيد صياح الى ان الامور
تدار بالشكل القانوني كيف يمكن ان نصف ذلك
وهؤلاء
الموقوفون لم يتم استنطاق الا مره واحده
تقريبا منذ سته
اشهر والملف قانونيا فارغ كما يقول كما
تقول هيئه الدفاع
وبالتالي لم يطلق سراحهم رغم ذلك بطبيعه
الحال انا نحترم الزملاء ونحترم هيئه
الدفاع من رجال القانون ومن الاكفاء وقلنا
هذا عديد المرات وجهنا اليهم تحيه شكر
طالما انا لسان دفاع في كل اقاع العالم
يدافع عن قضايا الحق وهذا امر لا نشكك فيه
لانني اتاسف جدا جدا لان الامر تغير
وانقلب يعني على الاعقاب بالنسبه لمن
يدافعون من كل الاطياف المدنيه والسياسيه
والحقوق على الموقوفين الذين هم الى حد
الساعه هم ابرياء بنصر القانون والدستور
تبقى احكام فاصل 33 من الدستور كل متهم
بري تثبط ادانته اذا هم مجرد مضمون فيهم
لما ماذا كل هذا التصعيد الم ربما هذا
التصعيد اسمح لي سيد صياح وان رئيس الدوله
نفسه قال هؤلاء مدانون حتى قبل ان تنظر
فيهم المحاكم واي قاض يبرئهم هو مدان
مثلهم اذا اذا الحكم تقريبا جاهز يعني لا
ليس الحكم جاهز يعني عندما تقرا الامور
بشكل
السياسي بمفهومه بمفهومه يعني الجانبي
تفهمه على ذلك الاساس كل رؤساء العالم سلت
الالفن وقالوا اكثر من هذا في كل الدول
حتى دول الديمقراطيه انا لكي لكي اضع كلام
الرئيس في مساره ولكي اعاتب الرئيس او
احتج على الرئيس يجب ان افند كلام الرئيس
بالحجه العادله بالقضاء نفسه لماذا القضاء
لن يحتج على هذا الامر اذا كان القضاء
مستقل طب طبقى احكام الماده 16 من قانونه
الوظيفي الداخلي الذي يجعل له سلطانا
ويرفع من شانه وقدوته ومقداره ويقول
بالحرف الواحد ان القضاء حر مستقل لسلطان
عليه للقانون هذه الماده 17 ولماذا
المواثيق الامميه كلها الماده 49 و 43 و
39 من ميثاق الامم المتحده التي وحتى حتى
الرئيس قيس سعيد سيد صياح الرئيس قيس سعيد
قال انه لا يرضى بالظلم واستنكر ان
تستمر ان يستمر الاستماع لهؤلاء لاكثر من
سته اشهر حتى انه قال باستنكار يستمع
لماذا كل هذه الفتره اذا هل يمكن ان نفهم
من ذلك اشاره الى ان القضيه قد تطوى
قريبا وهذا وهذا بطبيعه الحال يدعم كلامي
لانني ادافع في شق ما على النظام الجمهوري
وقيادته وسلطه البلاد الرئيس عندما ناخذ
هذا الجانب وشكرا لكم سييد محمد على هذه
النقطه بالذات وتحليل ممتاز جدا السيد
الرئيس عندما اتخذ هذا المعطى وقال انه
يكره الظلم وانه ضد الظلم ولماذا كل هته
المده لسته اشهر لماذا لماذا كل هذه
الملفات في الرفوف اذا كان هؤلاء الاشخاص
ابرياء يعني لماذا لا ناخذ كلام الرئيس في
هذا الاتجاه الايجابي وان الامور قد تتجه
الى الحلحل بعد اربعه اشهر تمديد للايقاف
كما تعلمون تم ايقافهم لمده سته اشهر ثم
سيمدد ذلك اربعه اشهر يعني من شهر اوت 18
اوت تقريبا شهر ونصف اخر احتمال كبير جدا
انه موقوفين يكونون في حال راح نحن نبحث
عن تهدئه الاجواء نبحث عن دوله فيها
العداله والكفاله كما كما صادقت عليه تونس
في كل القوق الامميه و هذا اتجاه الرئيس
واعتقد انه كما قال لا يريد الظلم لا يجعل
لنفسه معيارا للتشكيك فيما قاله منذ يومين
او ثلاثه وبالتالي يجب ان ناخذ كلام
الرئيس على انه كلام ايجابي ويكفي
المعارضه من التخد السياسي واللغو الذي لا
فائده منه شكرا جزيلا لك قيصر السياح من
[موسيقى]
سوسه افادت وكاله رويترز ان الولايه
المتحده وبريطانيا والنروج والمانيا تعتزم
التقدم بطلب الى مفوضيه الامم المتحده
الساميه لحقوق الانسان لاجراء تحقيق دولي
فيما قالت انها فضائع في السودان ووفق
وثيقه الطلب التي اطلعت عليها رويترز نددت
هذهه الدول بما قالت انها انتهاكات لحقوق
الانسان وفضائها ارتكبت خلال الصراع
المستمر منذ خمسه اشهر في السودان وتسعى
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والنروج
والمانيا الى تشكيل مهمه تقصي الحقائق من
ثلاثه اشخاص للتحقيق في هذا
الشان قالت مصادر عسكريه للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع قصفت بالمدفعيه مقر قياده
الجيش السوداني وسط العاصمه الخرطوم من
جهتها ذكرت مصادر محليه ان مسيره تابعه
للجيش نفذت ضربات استباقيه على تجمعات
للدعم السريع في منطقه الجريف غرب بولايه
الخرطوم بينما نفذت طائرات الجيش ضربات
على تجمعات الدعم السريه جنوبي الخرطوم
بالقرب من جامعه الرازي في حي المجاهدين
كما افاد مراسل الجزيره ان مدفعيه الجيش
قصفت عددا من مواقع الدعم السريع في ولايه
الخرطوم هذا وقال مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان خمسه مسلحين قتلوا واصيب اخرون
معظمهم موالون لقوات الدعم السريع اثناء
هجومهم على قافله مساعدات في منطقه بشيش
شمال دارفور وقال المتحدث باسم ما تعرف
بالقوه المشتركه لحركات الكفاح المسلح
الرائد احمد حسين للجزيره ان اثنين من
افراد قواته اصيب اثر هجوم مجهول الهويه
على قافله مساعدات انسانيه تحت حمايتهم
عند منطقه ام الحسين شرقيه الفاشر كانت
متجهه الى اقليمي دارفور وكردفان يذكر ان
القوه المشتركه لحركات الكفاح المسلح تعمل
بين حكومه السودان والحركات المسلحه على
تامين قوافل المساعدات الانسانيه الى غرب
السودان هذا ويواجه من بقي من سكان ولايه
الخرطوم نقص في الامدادات الغذائيه وشحا
في السيوله النقديه بسبب الحرب الدائره
ومما فاقم الوضع انتشار ظاهره السلب
والنهب واغلاق
المتاجر اثرت اسره محجوب الموظف باحدى
الجامعات الحكوميه البقاء بمنزلها رغم
استمرار الحرب في الخرطوم لع
اشهر الحياه هنا باتت قاسيه يصعب الحصول
على الاحتياجات الاساسيه شحت اغلب السلع
الضروريه وتضاعفت اسعار ما توفر
منها اسعار زائده كثير جدا حتى قش انا
شايله ما تمت اضطريت انقص بعض الحاجات
الشايله عشان تجي نفس المبلغ اللي انا
شايله لانهيت في تفاجات بان الازع زايده
كثير جدا من قبل الحرب ى بعد الحرب يعني
زياده في الازع اي حاجه بتكون تكون زاده
بنسبه
100% مع استمرار الحرب في جبهات قتاليه
عديده داخل العاصمه لا تتوفر ممرات امنه
لعبور المساعدات الغذائيه للسكان اضطر
بعضهم للاعتماد على ما يذهب الجوع فقط
الرز كان بيكون ب 1000 1 ونص حس لله ب
2000 ونص حاجات في زيادات ماشي في حاجات
زايده لانه الحرب دي طبعا اي حاجه زادت اي
شيء اي شيء زادته بالذات
الازعاج وبعدين ما في
كاش يقول التجار الذين ما زالوا يمارسون
نشاطهم داخل العاصمه ان موجه الغلاء سببها
توقف امدادات البضائع لاكثر من اربعه اشهر
وتعطل جميع المصانع داخل العاصمه دائما
كان في السوق المحلي في الالبان في الشاي
في الزيوت كان بنسبه 80% بتغطي السوق
والان كل المصانع يعني وقفت تضررت من
الحرب دي فاصبحت البضاء تاتي كلها من
الخارج من زيوت لالبان صوابين بدره جميع
السل السلع
الاساسيه مراقبون رسموا صوره قاتمه
للاوضاع الاقتصاديه مع استمرار الحرب في
ظل عجز اغلب المواطنين عن تلبيه
احتياجاتهم اليوميه
اكثر عامل ادى الى عدم الاستقرار
والزياده ابرزها انه حرب على صعيد
الصادرات والواردات
تعطلت ما لحق
بقطاع الصناعات التحويليه والقطاع التجاري
والمصرفي من دمار او من
تعطب بعض سلاء الغذائيه تضاعفت اسعارها
ناهيك عن الخبز الذي قفزت اسعاره لاكثر من
130% في ظل خراب ودمار طال اغلب الاسواق
الشعبيه بالمدينه ندره سلع الاساسيه
وارتفاع اسعارها فضلا عن شح السيوله
النقديه معاناه سيعيش من بقي من سكان
العاصمه تحت وطئتها الى ان تضع الحرب
اوزارها اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره
الخرطوم طالب كبير الديمقراطيين في لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس النواب الامريكي
جريجوري مكس طلب وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
بتعليق جزء من المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه الى مصر المرتبط بمعايير حقوق
الانسان وقال ميكس في بيان نشره على منصه
اكس ان الكونجرس يحتاج الى مزيد من
التوضيح من وزاره الخارجيه بشان كيفيه
تناول المخاوف المتعلقه بمعامله المعتقلين
السياسيين في مصر والصحفيين فضلا عن سياده
القانون في علاقات بلاده الثنائيه مع
القاهره مضيفا انه اتصل بوزير الخارجيه
انطوني بلينكن لحجم
230 مليون دولار من المساعدات العسكريه
المشروطه بحقوق الانسان ولكن تم حجب 85
مليونا
فقط اكدت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
شاب فلسطيني متاثرا بجراح كان اصيب بها
الليله خلال جراء اطلاق جنود الاحتلال
النار عليه في منطقه جبل الطويل في البيره
واوضحت الوزاره ان فلسطينيا اخر اصيب
بجروح في الاطراف السفليه وكان الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني قال ان قوات الاحتلال
منعت طواقمه من الوصول اليهما بينما قالت
مصادر اسرائيليه ان الشابين حاول القاء
زجاجات حارقه صوب موقع عسكري قرب مستوطنه
بجوت فسارع الجنود واطلقوا النار
عليهما قال الرئيس السنغالي ماكي سال ان
الانقلابات العسكريه ليست حلا لان الجيوش
غير مدربه على اداره الدول واصفا
الانقلابات بالوباء
واضاف سال في لقاء خاص ضمن برنامج
المقابله مع علي الظفيري ان مهمه الجيوش
تنحصر في الدفاع عن سياده الدول وسلامه
اراضيها لقد اصبح الامر وباء لكن قناعتي
هي ان الانقلاب ليس حلا لان الجيوش غير
مدربه على اداره الدول ولكن للدفاع عن
البلاد والدفاع عن سيادتها وعن سلامه
اراضيها ولكل عمله ووظيفته وهذه الوظيفه
نبيله وجديله بالثناء لكنهم غير مدربين
على اداره الدول وبناء على ذلك فاللجوء
الى الانقلاب ليس حلا للمشكلات التي
تواجهها
بلداننا وفيما يتعلق بالانتقادات الموجهه
الى الوجود والدور الفرنسي في افريقيا دع
سال باريز الى التعلم من اخطائها والمواقف
السابقه من اجل تقديم نفسها بشكل افضل
وصياغه علاقتها مع البلدان الا
الافريقيه تعرف انا لست هنا للدفاع عن
فرنسا لكنني اعتقد ايضا انه لا ينبغي لنا
ان نعتبر الافارقه بمثابه خدام المذبح حتى
ان البعض يعتقد ان فرنسا موجوده هناك
لتستولي على مواردنا بادئ ذي بدء هي لا
تملك حتى القدره لفعل ذلك حتى لو ارادت
ويوجد احيانا حكم لا يتوافق مع الواقع
الفعلي للامور فالسن جال التي اتراس
السنغال التي قامت بتنويع شركائها منذ ان
اصبحت رئيسها يوجد هنا صينيون وهم يعملون
بكل حريه واتراك ويعملون بكل حريه فرنسيون
والمان وامريكي الجميع موجود هنا لماذا
تريدون ان تصدقوا ان السنغال على سبيل
المثال لانها تتكلم الفرنسيه فان فرنسا هي
من يقرر يفعل ما يشاء هذا لا يتوافق مع
الواقع على الاقل في السنغال ولكن هناك
فعلا سياسه تقريع ضد فرنسا اذا جاز
التعبير والتي تتلخص في تدمير صوره فرنسا
في افريقيا وقد تنجح هذه السياسه اذا لم
تتمكن فرنسا من كبح جماح هذه الحمله
المكثفه التي ساعدت شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي في نشرها وفي المقابل يتعين على
الجانب الفرنسي ايضا ان يتعلم من الاخطاء
والمواقف السابقه حتى يتمكن من تقديم
الصوره الحقيقيه لفرنسا في علاقاتها مع
افريقيا
ننوه الى ان اللقاء مع الرئيس السنغالي
ماكي سال سيبث كاملا ضمن برنامج المقابله
يوم الاحد الساعه العاشره و5 دقائق مساء
بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه يستمر تدفق عشرات الالاف من طالبي
اللجوء من دول امريكا اللاتينيه الى
الحدود الامريكيه المكسيكيه حيث تجاوزت
اعداد من عبروا الحدود خلال الاسبوع
الحالي ال 50 الف شخص معظمهم من فينزوي
وياتي هذا رغم حاجز الاسلاك الشائكه الذي
دشنه الحرس الوطني على الضفه الامريكيه
لنهر ريو جراندي الفاصل بين ولايه تكساس
والمكسيك قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن مكارتي انه سيقدم للتصويت مشروع
قانون في اطار اجراء مؤقت للحيلوله دون
اغلاق الحكومه
ولتاكيد
ان على كل نائب في مجلس النواب ان يوضح
اذا كان يدعم سياسه تامين الحدود او سياسه
الحدود المفتوحه التي قال ان الرئيس جو
بايدن
يتبناها لا افهم سبب استمرار الرئيس بايدن
والديمقراطيين في الكونجرس في تجاهل امن
الحدود وتجاهل دعوات قيادات
ديمقراطيه لهذا السبب اقدم للتصويت مشروع
قانون يتضمن تدابير مؤك قته من شانها
تمويل الحكومه وتامين الحدود لم يعد
بامكان الرئيس بايدن تجاهل مشكله تسبب
فيها هو شخصيا وتؤدي الى قتل امريكيين كل
يوم يتعين على كل عضو ان يحسم موقفه اما
الوقوف مع تامين الحدود او الاصطفاف مع
الرئيس لصالح حدود
مفتوحه اعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا
بتجديد تفويض الدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده اعتراض السفن المستخدمه في تهريب
المهاجرين او الاتجار بالبشر في اعالي
البحار قباله سواحل ليبيا لمده سنه اضافيه
ودان القرار جميع اعمال تهريب المهاجرين
والاتجار بالبشر كما دع الدول الاعضاء الى
وضع حقوق الانسان والاحتياجات الفوريه
للمهاجرين واللاجئين في صميم جهودها
الراميه الى منع ومكافحه التهريب وقد صوتت
جميع الدول الاعضاء بالمجلس لصالح القرار
باستثناء روسيا التي امتنعت عن
التصويت مستمرون معكم في جوله الحصاد وفي
العناوين مع نزوح اكثر من 100 الف من ارمن
كارباخ الى ارمينيا الامم المتحده تعلن
ارسال بعثه انسانيه الى الاقليم للمره
الاولى منذ 30 عاما شرطه اذربيجان تنتشر
في كارباخ وموسكو تقول انها ستناقش مع
باكو مستقبل قوات حفظ السلام
الروسيه هجمات جديده بالمسيرات تستهدف
العمق الروسي بالتزامن مع معارك شرقيه
وجنوبيه اوكرانيا بوتين يطلب من مساعد
سابق لبريجو جن الاشراف على متطوعين
للقتال في اوكرانيا والكرملين يعلن توقيع
350 الف مقاتل عقودا مع وزاره
الدفاع
في احدث حلقات التازم بين الرئيس سعيد
والمعارضه بتونس راشد الغنوشي يبدا اضرابا
عن الطعام تضامنا مع القيادي بجبهه الخلاص
المعتقل جوهر بن مبارك والشاب يدعو الى
حجد الجهود للتصدي لاحتكار السلطه والحكم
التعسفي اهلا بكم من جديد
قال المفوض السامي للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين ان اكثر من 100 ال من ارمني
كارباخ نزحوا الى ارمينيا وقد اعلنت الامم
المتحده ان بعثه لتقييم الاحتياجات
الاساسيه ستصل الى اقليم كارباخ بنهايه
هذا الاسبوع وذلك في خطوه هي الاولى من
نوعها منذ نحو ثلاثه عقود ونقل مراسل
الجزيره عن مصادر محليه القول ان الشرطه
الاذربيجانيه بدات الانتشار في ستيبان كار
كيرت عاصمه الاقليم واظهرت صور انتشار
الشرطه الاذربيجانيه في شوارع
العاصمه في غضون ذلك اعلنت اداره امن
الحدود الاذربيجانيه اعتقال لوفا متشكي
انيان التي شغلت منصب وزيره الدفاع فيما
كان يعرف بحكومه جمهوريه كارباخ بين عامي
و208 وقالت الاداره في بيان لها ان عمليه
الاعتقال جرت عند النقطه الحدوديه في معبر
لاتين اثناء محاولتها العبور نحو ارمينيا
كما ذكر جهاز امن الدوله في اذربيجان انه
اعتقل ديفيد مانوكيان النائب الاول لقائد
ما يعرف بجيش كارباخ خلال محاولته عبور
المعبر ذاته الى ارمينيا ووجهت ل مانوكيان
تهم عده ابرزها دعم الارهاب واداره
مجموعات مسلحه وتزويدها بالاسلحه
والمتفجرات على الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه قالت محكمه العدل الدوليه ان
ارمينيا طلبت منها ان تامر اذربيجان بسحب
جميع قواتها من المنشات المدنيه في اقليم
كارباخ وتسهيل وصول الامم المتحده الى
المنطقه وكانت المحكمه الدوليه قد اصدرت
في فبراير شباط الماضي قرارا يدعو
اذربيجان لضمان حريه الحركه عبر ممر
لاتشين الذي يربط اقليم كارباخ مع
ارمينيا وفي ريفيان قال وزير الدفاع
الارميني ان الباب مفتوح امام عناصر ما
كان يعرف بجيش كارباخ للانضمام الى الجيش
الارمني من جهته افادت السلطات الارمنيه
ان عدد النازحين من اقليم كارباخ الى
ارمينيا ارتفع الى نحو 90,000 وقالت
المتحدثه باسم رئيس الوزراء الارماني انه
تم تامين سكن مؤقت لنحو
20300 من
النازحين قال الكريملين ان مساله ابرام
معاهده السلام بين ارمينيا اذربيجان ما
تزال ذات اهميه واضاف الكريملين ان موسكو
ستناقش مع باكو مستقبل قوات حفظ السلام
الروسيه الموجوده على على اراضي
اذربيجان من جانب اخر بحث رئيس البرلمان
الارماني الين سيمونيان ونظيره الاوكراني
روسلان ستيف تشكوك في العاصمه الايرلنديه
دبلا الاوضاع في اقليم كارباخ ونزوح
السكان الارمني منه وقالت وسائل واعلام
ارمينيه ان اللقاء جاء على هامش اجتماع
لممثلي برلمانات دول مجلس اوروبا واشارت
الى ان المسؤول الاوكراني اكد على اهميه
التعاون بين كيف
[موسيقى]
وفان نعت قوه دفاع البحرين احد افرادها
برتبه ملازم اول توفي اليوم متاثرا بجراح
كان اصيب بها يوم الاث اثنين في هجوم
للحوثيين على الحدود الجنوبيه بالسعوديه
وبذلك يرتفع عدد القتلى في هذا الهجوم الى
اربعه عسكريين
بحرينيين هذا وقد دان مجلس الامن الدولي
ما وصفه بالهجوم الفضيع المنسوب للحوثيين
باستعمال المسيرات على افراد من القوات
المسلحه البحرينيه العامله ضمن التحالف
العربي لدعم الشرعيه في اليمن واعتبره
عملا تصعيدي وقال المجلس في بيان صحفي
تمده اليوم ان الهجوم يشكل تهديدا خطيرا
لعمليه السلام والاستقرار الاقليمي بما في
ذلك في اليمن ودعى الحوثييين الى انهاء
جميع الهجمات الارهابيه وجدد المجلس
الاعراب عن قلقه ايزاء استهداف البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في المدن الواقعه على
الحدود الجنوبيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودعى مجلس الامن كل الاطراف الى احترام
التزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي بما في
ذلك القانون الدولي الانساني
[موسيقى]
الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ طلب
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من قائد
اركان فاجنر السابق اندريه تروشي الاشراف
على تشكيل وحدات تطوعيه يمكنها اداء مهام
قتاليه متعدده خصوصا فيما تسميها موسكو
منطقه العمليه العسكر الخاصه ياتي هذا في
وقت تواصل فيه روسيا حجد مزيد من القوات
للقتال في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت في وقت سابق
تقدم نحو 350 الف متطوع للقتال تحت امره
وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يقف الرئيس الروسي دقيقه صمت على
ارواح متطوعين قتلوا في حرب اوكرانيا يشيد
بوتين بالاف من السجناء الجنائيين قاتلوا
في اوكرانيا نظير وعود باطلاق سراحهم يقول
ان هؤلاء سددوا دينهم للمجتمع يدشن بوتين
مرحله ما بعد يجين بريغوجين فلم يعد اسم
فاجنر يتردد في الكرملين ولا في اروقه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تستعيد موسكو عنه
بما تسميها كتائب المتطوعين وهم ممن
يتطوعون للقتال في اوكرانيا ولكن شرط ان
يدينوا بالولاء لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يضع بوتين امر عشرات الاف
المتطوعين بين يدي اندريه تروشي او ما
يعرف بيدوي الاشيب وهو احد القاده
السابقين في فاجنر ويوصف بانه كان حلقه
الوصل بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سيقود تروش جزء من
350 الف مقاتل تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
منذ بدايه العام في الحادي من سبتمبر من
العام الماضي اعلن الرئيس الروسي تعبئه
عسكريه جزئيه للدفاع عن الاراضي الروسيه
كانت هذه التعبئه العسكريه الاولى في
روسيا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفقا
لهذا المرسوم استدعي نحو 300 ال من جنود
الاحتياط وهم جزء من نحو 25 مليونا هم
اجمالي قوه الاحتياط لدى روسيا وهم جميع
المواطنين الذين ادوا الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه وقد امر بوتين انذاك بان تشمل
تعبئه السجناء ممن ادينوا بارتكاب جرائم
خطيره فمنذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا جندت
مجموعه فاجنر ومثلها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عشرات الاف المعتقلين في السجون الروسيه
مقابل وعود بالافراج عنهم لكن زج بهم في
جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا بعد نحو عام على
قرار بوتين على التعبئه يكشف الكرملين عن
قوه عسكريه ثانيه قوامها نحو 350 ال شخص
وقعوا جميعا عقودا مع وزاره الدفاع منذ
بدايه العام الحالي للقتال في اوكرانيا
الحد الادنى للاجر الشهري الذي يعرض على
الجنود المتعاقدين نحو 2700 دولار وهو ما
يقرب من ثلاثه اضعاف متوسط الاجور في
روسيا الى جانب ذلك استدعت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اخيرا 130 الف شخص ممن يستوفون
متطلبات قانون الخدمه العسكريه فيما يعرف
بتجنيد الخري
تحشد روسيا وتعيد ترتيب صفوف قواتها ما
يشي بجوله جديده من القتال في اوكرانيا
اكثر شراسه فمقابل التحشيد الروسي تتوالى
شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه على كيف تدخل
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه الى ساحه المعارك
لتضاف الى نظيرتها الالمانيه ليبرد وهي
بعض من 31 دبابه وعدت الولايات المتحده في
يناير الماضي بتسليمها للجيش الاوكراني
ومن المتوقع ان تتسلم كيف ايضا خلال ايام
صواريخ اكمس ارض ارض وهي صواريخ بالستيه
بعيده المدى موجهه وشديده الدقه يصل مداها
الى نحو 300
ر وفي التطورات الميدانيه للحرب اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احبط هجوم اوكراني
وتدمير احد ع طائره مسيره في اجواء مقاطعه
كالوجا وكورس الروسيتين خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولم تذكر وزاره الدفاع تفاصيل
بشان خسائر ماديه نتيجه هذا
الهجوم على الجانب الاوكراني اعلن الجيش
سقوط ثلاثه قتلى وخمسه جرحى في قصف روسي
استهدف مدينه خيرسون جنوبي البلاد واضاف
ان هجمات روسيه استهدفت 140 بلده خلال
الساعات ال4 الماضيه في مقاطعات تشيرنيهيف
وسومي وخاركوف ودونيتسك
زبروجيا وخير سون واشار الجيش الى انه خاض
اكثر من 20 اشتباكا مع القوات
الروسيه ينضم الينا من بيلي جورد الخبير
العسكري والعقيد السابق جنادي الكن ومن
كيف اوليكسي
ميلينج مساعد وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني السابق واذا بدئنا بدانا بضيفنا
من بيلجراد الخبير العسكري العقيد السابق
السيد الكين
هل الاخبار الاخيره تشير الى تعبئه اضافيه
اقوى لروسيا في حربها مع
اوكرانيا لاقول ان الاخبار
الاخيره على الاقل من الوجه الرسمي تتحدث
عن اننا سوف نمر بمراحل تعبئه جديده ان
امر
الرئيس
كدعوه خريفيه للخدمه العسكريه و الممثل
الرسمي لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنوا انه
لن يكون هناك اي خطط على
تعبئه جديده من قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وليس هناك اي نظر بهذا الموضوع ولكن سوف
تستمر مراكز التعبئه والتجنيد باستقبال
المتطوعين
وكذلك ال الجنود السابقين المتقاعدين
الذين يريدون ان يوقعوا عقودا مع وزاره
الدفاع وهم يسموا يسموا
بموقعي العقود
ولذلك المصادر الرسميه الروسيه
لا لم تعلن عن اي تعبئه جديده اضافيه ولا
تحتاج لهذا بعد ما مرت التعبئه الجزئيه
وبعد ما انضمت القوات للجبهات
وللعمل العسكريه الخاصه لا ادري ان كان
السيد اولكسي ملنك من كيف يتبنى نفس هذا
الراي بخصوص هذه الموجات من المتطوعين
والتي وصلت الى 350 الف
الصعب القول لاي درجه ولاي حد هذه
المعلومات التي اصدرت من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لاي درجه هي متناسبه مع الواقع
لانه كان هناك لاكثر من مره تلاعب
بالارقام
عندما تم اعان
عقودا مع من تم تعبئتهم والبعض اجبروا على
توقيع هذه العقود ولكن
الان فعلا بتقديرنا في الاشهر القادمه لن
يكون هناك تعبئه جماعيه في روسيا
لانه كل مراكز
التجنيد اي المؤسسات المسؤوله عن التعبئه
سوف يكونوا مشغولين ب
جمع الجنود السابقين جنود الاحتياط ولذلك
الاشهر القادمه لان لن تشهد اي تعبئه
ولكني اعتقد ان روسيا ستضطر للقيام بهذا
لانهم فعلا بحاجه المزيد من القوى
العسكريه لان قوات الاحتياط اصبحت في
نهايتها سيد الكن هل هل الامر يشير الى
انهاك حقيقي اصاب الجيش الروسي حتى وان
كان الامر يتعلق بمتطوعين وليس بتعبئه
رسميه كنت لاقول
ان الحديث عن
استنزاف اؤكد انه في الاحتياط
لدينا
حوالي
300 100 ال جندي هم جزء منهم من تم
تعبئتهم جزئيا في العام الماضي وايضا ق
متطوعين ومن وقعوا العقود اي
المستاجرين لذلك اريد ان اقول ان هذه
الاحتياطات جزء منها فقط انضمت
للمعارك في بعض المحاور من الجبهات حيث
نقاط التمام فاذا بشكل
احتياط القوات العسكريه في الجيش
الروسي لم يستخدم بعد سيد الكن ايضا لقاء
الرئيس بوتين بالقائد السابق لفاجنر
والحديث عن ربما نوع من تشكيل جديد يمكن
ان ان ان يرى النور قريبا كيف يمكن ان
نفهم
ذلك
اليوم كان هناك لقاء الرئيس الروسي السيد
ومرتين ليس مع رئيس سابق لوا بل مع
الضابط اندري تروش الذي كان رئيسا للهيئه
العسكريه في الشركه العسكريه الخاصه واغنر
هذه الشركه لم تعد موجوده في الواقع جزء
كبير من قوات فاغنر وقعت عقود مع وزاره
الدفاع وجزء
اخر قرروا ان
يستمروا بالخدمه العسكريه في حرس في الحرس
الوطني
وال السيد
تروشي اليوم كان لديه حديث مع الرئيس كما
قلت
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الذي حاور معه
مسائل ما هي المهام التي سوف يقوم بها
اندري تروشي شخصيا وكما قال الرئيس بوتين
في هذا اللقاء وكما قال السيد سكوف
تروشي الان يعمل في اطار وتحت مظله وزاره
الدفاع وسوف يقوم باعمال مشتركه بين
القوات قوات المتطوعين الموجودين الان في
الجبهات ووزاره الدفاع
اذا شركه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه لم تعد
موجوده في الواقع كما
يسموهم
الموسيقيين بل تم توزيعهم بالجبهات
والان الحديث كان بشكل خاص اثناء اللقاء
عن الاعمال والضمانات الاجتماعيه التي سوف
تقدمها وم ذلك اسمحلي سيد الكن مع ذلك
التطور هام ولهذا اسال ضيفنا من كياف سيد
ملك عما اذا كان هذا التطور يمكن ان
يشكل عنصر اضافي مقلق بالنسبه
لكيف
اولا هذه الشركه التي تسمى شركه واجنر او
ما يسمى بالشركه العسكريه الخاصه كانت
تشكيلات غير قانونيه لانه حتى القانون
الروسي الداخلي هذه الشركات العسكريه
الخاصه تعتبر شركات غير قانونيه وتعتبر
ويعتبر جنودها مرتزقه خارجين على القانون
فعندما نرى الرئيس الروسي يلتقي بقياداته
هذا يعني انه يلتقي بمجرمين حسب القانون
الروسي هم هو التقى مع بريغوجين ويلتقي مع
خليفته الان
وهذه الاشخاص تقوم الان بمهام صعبه جدا
اولا ان يقوموا بالتنسيق مع الجنود الذين
بقوا ويخدمون في الجبهات لانهم فعلا هناك
الكثير من الجنود حتى النظاميين المحتاجين
للتحضير والتدريب لان قوات واغنر تعلمون
انهم مجرمين محترفين والشيء الثاني
فاجنر كانت شكلت تهديد لنظام بوتين لانه
في عندما وقعت الاحداث حوالي 10 الاف شخص
توجهوا لموسكو
الجميع ارتعب من هذا وكان بوتين على
راسهم بوتين ارتعب ايضا لذلك يحاولون الان
بنشر هذه القوات بمختلف التشكيلات
العسكريه اما
الرئيس الجديد حسب علمي فهو ليس له مرجعيه
وسط قوات واجنر لذلك ما هو مصيره في
المستقبل في هذه الشركه من الصعب التنبؤ
بهذا شكرا جزيلا لك اولكسي ملك من كيف
شكرا لك ايضا من
بجرود جنادي
الكن
قالت حركه النهضه التونسيه ان رئيسها راشد
الغنوشي بدا اضرابا عن الطعام لمده ثلاثه
ايام متتاليه دفاعا عن مطلب كل المعتقلين
السياسيين باطلاق سراحهم واضافت ان
الغنوشي دخل الاضراب تضامنا مع القيادي
بجبهه الخلاص جوهر بن مبارك المضرب عن
الطعام منذ الثلاثاء الماضي من جهتها دعت
جبهه الخلاص الى تعديل موازين القوى لدفع
السلطه للتراجع عنما وصفتها باجراءات ه
الغ
شمه منعطف جديد تدخله الازمه بين الرئيس
قيس سعيد ومعارضيه في تونس التي تشهد منذ
فبراير الماضي حمله توقيفات شملت اعلاميين
ونشطاء وقضاه ورجال اعمال
وسياسيين يتهم سعيد المعتقلين بالتامر على
امن الدوله والتخابر مع دبلوماسيين غربيين
والفساد المالي ويصفهم بالارهابيين خونه
بينما تتهمه المعارضه باستخدام القضاء
لملاحقتهم والاصرار على ابعادهم بموجب
ملفات تصفها بالفاره ولا تستند على اي
دلائل او قرائن تدين المعتقلين او تبرر
اعتقالهم ورغم ذلك يتم رفض الافراج عنهم
دون وجه قانوني في جديد المواجهه يتواصل
اضراب الجوع في تونس رئيس حركه النهضه
راشد الغنوشي المعتقل دخل الجمعه في اضراب
عن الطعام مدته ثلاثه ايام لكن الخطوه في
جوهرها تاتي ضمن المطالب المتصاعده باطلاق
سراح جميع المعتقلين السياسيين على خلفيه
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي يفرضها الرئيس
سعيد منذ يوليو عام
2021 جبهه الخلاص المعارضه دعت لتعديل
موازين القوى لدفع السلطه للتراجع
عن اجراءاتها وستنفذ حسب رئيسها احمد نجيب
الشابي مع بدايه الاسبوع المقبل فعاليات
تضامنيه مع جوهر بن مبارك تعبر عن
الاحتجاج على ما اعتبرته مهزله قضائيه
ومظلمه تستهدف جميع التونسيين السلطه لا
تستهدف السياسيين وحدهم بل تستهدف
الاعلاميين
والمدونين
والفنانين
تستهدف
النقابيين وتستهدف رجال الاعمال وتستهدف
المسؤولين في المؤسسات العموميه وتستهدف
عشرات الالاف من الموظفين الثابت ان تونس
تسير منذ اجراءات الخ من يوليو عام
2021 في خطين متوازيين الرئيس قيس سعيد
وبعد تكريس سلطاته في دستور اقر العام
الماضي خلال استفتاء شهد مقاطعه سياسيه
وشعبيه يصف اجراءاته بانها ضروريه لانقاذ
تونس من الفوضى بينما يرى معارضوه في تلك
الاجراءات ومن بنى عليها من قرارات
احتكارا للسلطه وانهيار للحريات بعد تفكيك
المؤسسات وتمزيق الدستور
السابق
هجومان داميان ضرب باكستان اليوم
57 قتيلا على الاقل وعشرات الجرحى في
تفجيرين استهدف على نحو لافت مسجدين في
اقليمين منفصلين وبينما توعدت السلطات من
وصفتها بالجماعات الارهابيه والجهات التي
تمولها وتدربها لم تعلن بعد اي جهه
مسؤوليتها عما
جرى حداد لثلاثه ايام في بلوشستان جنوب
غربي
باكستان من تكبيرات واناشيد دينيه الى
صراخات الاستغاثه لانقاذ الجرحى وانتشال
جثث القتلى انهى تفجير انتحاري وهو ليس
الوحيد في البلاد الاحتفالات بالمولد
النبوي الشريف بمشاهد مرعبه قتل فيها
العشرات واصيب عدد كبير بجروح خرجت
المواكب من عده مساجد لتلتقي عند نقطه
تجمع فرقهم فيها دوي الانفجار الذي وقع
بالقرب من سياره للشرطه عند مسجد وفق
روايه شهود عيان اكتظت مستشفيات ماستون
بالضحايا ووصفت اصابات العديد من الجرحى
بالخطير كان الجهه التي تقف وراء هذه
الهجمات كانت مصره على اطاله فاجعه
الباكستانيين اذ وقع انفجاران اخران
احدهما عند بوابه المسجد والاخر في الصح
في اقليم خيبر بختونخوا بولايه بشاور قتل
ما لا يقل عن اربعه اشخاص في حصيله
اعلنتها الشرطه كان العدد سيكون اكبر لو
لم يحدث اشتباك بين قوات الامن ومسلحين
يحملان رشاشات اليه وقنابل يدويه وسترات
ناسفه حاول اختراق التدابير الامنيه حصر
تحت انقاض سقف المسجد الذي وقع من شده
التفجير ما لا يقل عن 30 مصليا لم تعلن اي
جهه مسؤوليتها عن التفجيرات في مناطق لها
تاريخ في نشاط الجماعات المسلحه المتشدده
والانفصال ايضا اول رد فعل رسمي كان من
وزير الداخليه الباكستاني في الحكومه
المؤقته قال ان بلاده لن تدخر جهدا من اجل
القضاء على الارهابيين والجهات التي تعمل
على تمويلهم
وتجهيزهم استهدفوا المواطنين الذين كانوا
يحتفلون بمولد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
اؤكد لكم ان الدوله تقف الى جانب
المظلومين وستبذل كل ما في وسعها لدحر
هؤلاء المجرمين وقواتنا المسلحه لديها
القدره على تتبع الارهابيين وتوجيه ضربات
ضد الجهات التي تمولهم وتدربهم اينما
كانت سبق ان عاشت باكستان تفجيرات مماثله
خلال نفس المناسبه الدينيه قتل انتحري في
ابريل ست 50 شخصا على الاقل في مدينه
كراتشي الساحليه عندما فجر نفسه وسط موكب
المحتفلين تحبس باكستان انفاسها كلما
اقترب موعد الانتخابات المقرره في يناير
المقبل يعاني البلد من ازمه سياسيه وشلل
اقتصادي وتصعيد في الهجمات المسلحه اما
بتوقيع طالبان باكستان او تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ولايه خرسان كانت جمعه داميه
مواكب المحتفلين بمولد خاتم الانبياء
والمرسلين حولها الانتحاريون الى مواكب
جنازات وانضم الينا من اسلام اباد الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي محمد علي اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد علي هل عرف المزيد عن خلفيه ما
جرى بالفعل اعتقد ان التحقيقات سوف تتطلب
بعض الوقت لكي تنجلي الحقيقه
ولكن السلطات
الباكستانيه اوضحت ان اختيار الاهداف
والتوقيت بالاحتفال بالمولد النبوي الشريف
كل ذلك يشير الى ان داعش قد تكون خلف هذه
العمليه وهي تنشط او تنظيم داعش ينشط في
افغانستان والتمويل
والمواد من الوكالات الاستخباريه الهنديه
لان لديها الدوافع الاساسيه لكي لا يتنبه
العالم على الازمه الاخيره بين الهند
وكندا وبالاضافه الى
ذلك تو الهند انلا تصل الاستثمارات
الخارجيه المباشره الى باكستان وان لا
يشجعوا الصين على الاستثمار في باكستان
وفي بلوجستان على وجه الخصوص ولكن ما تشير
اليه الان من اتهام للهند هل يمكن ان تسير
فيه ايضا الحكومه الباكستانيه بمثل هذا
الوضوح نعم
لاسباب ثلاثه السبب الاول وبكل وضوح هو ان
الاضواء عالميا مسلطه على الازمه الاخيره
بعد اغتيال زعيم السيخ في كندا بالاضافه
الى الاعمال الشغبه التي تحصل في الهند
اذا الهند بحاجه الى تشتيت الانتباه عن
ذلك ثانيا اليوم هو الاحتفال بمولد خاتم
الانبياء المولد النبوي الشريف وهو من بين
الاحتفالات المقدسه ولا احد يمكنه ان
يتخيل ان اي مسلم يمكنه ان
يقتل مسلمين اخرين يحتفلون بمولد النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم نحن نتحدث عن اشخاص
يحتفلون بمناسبه دينيه وهذا يشير الى ان
اي شخص مسلم ليس وراء هذه العمليه يعني لا
توجد اي شبهه طائفيه او مذهبيه في
الموضوع ليس حقا لان بلوشستان
كاقيه في السابق ولكن معظم العنف الذي
شاهدناه في بلوشستان كان مستندا الى
الاعتبارات العرقيه الاثنيه الانفصاليه
المحليه غير ان هذا الحادث على وجه الخصوص
يشير الى ان بعض الجهات المنضوي تحت لواء
داعش هي خلفه تعمل من افغانستان ولكنها
تحصل على المعدات والتمويل من الهند وهناك
ادله تم تشاركها بشكل مستمر من باكستان مع
الامم المتحده كجزء من ملف موسع شكرا لك
محمد علي من اسلام
[موسيقى]
اباد افادت وكاله رويترز ان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا والنرويج والمانيا
تعتزم التقدم بطلب الى مفوضيه الامم
المتحده الساميه لحقوق الانسان لاجراء
تحقيق دولي فيما قالت انها فضائع في
السودان ووفق وثيقه الطلب التي اطلعت
عليها رويترز نددت هذه الدول بما قالت
انها انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان وفضائح
ارتكبت خلال الصراع المستمر منذ خمسه اشهر
في السودان وتسعى الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا والنروج والمانيا الى تشكيل
مهمه تقصي حقائق من ثلاثه اشخاص للتحقيق
في هذا
الشان قالت مصادر عسكريه للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع قصفت بالمدفعيه مقر قياده
الجيش السوداني وسط الخرطوم من جهتها ذكرت
مصادر محليه ان مسيره تابعه للجيش نفذت
ضربات استباقيه على تجمعات للدعم السريع
في منطقه الجريف غرب بولايه الخرطوم بينما
نفذت طائرات الجيش ضربات على تجمعات الدعم
السريع جنوبيه الخرطوم بالقرب من جامعه
الرازي في حي المجاهدين كما افاد مراسلنا
ان مدفعيه الجيش قصفت عددا من مواقع الدعم
السريه في ولايه
[موسيقى]
الخرطوم قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن مكارثي انه سيقدم للتصويت مشروع
قانون في اطار اجراء مؤقت للحيلوله دون
اغلاق الحكومه
ولتاكيد
ان على كل نائب في مجلس النواب ان يوضح ما
اذا كان يدعم سياسه تامين الحدود او سياسه
الحدود المفتوحه التي قال ان الرئيس
يتبناها لا افهم سبب استمرار الرئيس بايدن
والديمقراطيين في الكونجرس في تجاهل امن
الحدود وتجاهل دعوات قيادات ديمقراطيه
لهذا السبب اقدم للتصويت مشروع قانون
يتضمن تدابير مؤقته من شانها تمويل
الحكومه وتامين الحدود لم يعد بامكان
الرئيس بايدن تجا لمشكله تسبب فيها هو
شخصيا وتؤدي الى قتل امريكيين كل يوم
يتعين على كل عضو ان يحسم موقفه اما
الوقوف مع تامين الحدود او الاصطفاف مع
الرئيس لصالح حدود
مفتوحه ضم الينا من واشنطن جيرمي ماير
استاذ السياسه العامه في جماعه جورج ميسن
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
ماير
موضوع الاغلاق الحكومي هل بات الان
تقريبا
اكيد تقريبا نتحدث عن نسبه 100% انه ما من
حلول سوف نصل اليها قبل المهله الزمنيه
على الاقل سوف يكون هناك اغلاق حكوميا
ليوم يومين ما من مشكله اذا ما تم به بهذه
الحدود ولكن اذا ما استمر الاغلاق
الحكوميه لاسبوع تبدا التبعات يعني ما هي
هذه التتابعات التي يمكن ان ان
تكون سوف نشهد موظفينا حكوميين لا يحصلون
على الرواتب وطبعا هناك اشخاص يعتمدون على
الرواتب الشهريه ل كي
ينفقوا ويصرف في خلال الشهر وبالتالي سوف
تعاني الاسر الامريكيه من مشاكل بالاضافه
الى الاقتصاد الكلي والحكومه ايضا تقدم
خدمات متعدده ل الشركات مجددا اذا ما
تحدثنا عن مده اسبوعين على سبيل المثال
هناك مشكله بالنسبه الى الشركات في امريكا
وهل هذا
وارد نعم نعم هناك تكتل من ضمن
الاكثريه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب تنظر
الى الحكومه تقريبا على انها العدو البعض
منهم يقول الاغلاق الحكومي سوف يكون
ممتازا والامريكيون سوف يكتشفون ان الامر
ليس بذك السوء ان يكونوا من دون حكومه
فاعله طبعا هم لا يمثلون الاكثريه في
الحزب الجمهوري ولكنهم اصوات موجوده اصوات
موجوده ويبدو ان اصوات معطله لاي قرار
داخل الحزب الجمهوري في هذا
الشان نعم بالفعل ونحن نتحدث عن مجموعه
صغيره من الناخبين في بعض الدوائر
الانتخابيه التي تنتخب اليمين ولكن لان
مكارثي لديه اكثريه باربع اصوات فقط اربع
مقاعد يتعين عليه ان يصغي اليهم هو ضعيف
للغايه بالمقارنه مثلا مع ننسي بيلوسي هو
شخصيا وكانه مستعبد بين مزدوجين ل اولئك
الذين يودون ان يملوا التصويت على الحزب
الجمهوري ولكن ما اشرت اليه قبل قليل هل
يمكن ان ينقلب على الحزب الجمهوري بمعنى
انه اذا سرنا الى الاغلاق
فقد تصبح شعبيه الحزب الجمهوري في في وضع
صعب للغايه
انا عمري 55 عاما وترقعت في واشنطن في
الثمانينيات من القرن الماضي الجمهوريون
كانوا يلقون اللوم على الديمقراطيين ولكن
كل الاغلاقات الحكوميه ادت الى القاء
اللوم على الطرف الذي كان يخاطر بالوصول
الى الاغلاق الحكومي ولا طالم كان هذا
الطرف الجمهوريون وبالتالي الديمقراطيون
لا يحبذون الاغلاق الحكومي هناك طرف ياخذ
الطرف الاخر
رهينه شكرا جزيلا لك جيرمي ماير استاذ
السياسه العامه في جماعه جورج
ميسن يستمر تدفق عشرات الالاف من طالبي
اللجوء من دول امريكا اللاتينيه الى
الحدود الامريكيه المكسيكيه حيث تجاوزت
اعداد من عبروا الحدود خلال الاسبوع
الحالي الخم الف شخص معظمهم من فنزويلا
ياتي هذا رغم حاجز الاسلاك الشائكه الذي
دشنه الحرس الوطني على الضفه الامريكيه
لنهر ريو جراندي الفاصل بين ولايه تكساس
والمكسيك ينضم الينا الان من الحدود
الامريكيه المكسيكيه مراسل الجزيره احمد
هزيم اهلا بك
احمد كيف هي الصوره الان
لديك
محمد منذ ساعات الصباح و نشاهد افواج من
هؤلاء طالبين اللجوء يعبرون نهر ريو
جراندي وهو هذا النهر الذي تشاهدونه خلفي
في الصوره وتشاهدون الان البعض من هؤلاء
طالبي اللجوء ممن يحاولون عبور النهر
باتجاه عناصر من حرس الحدود الامريكي
يسلمون انفسهم لهؤلاء الحرس ياخذونه بعدها
الى مراكز ايواء اللاجئين بتوثيق حالاتهم
ويقدم هناك طلبات اللجوء الخاصه بهم على
ان يطلق سراحهم بانتظار موعد المحاكمه هذا
الم هذا هذه الفجوه التي تشاهدونها في
السياج من الاسلاك شائكه هي واحده من من
بضع فجوات موجوده على طول ضفه النهر
الامريكيه يعبر عبرها ال الطالبين لجوء
القادمين من في اغلبهم من فنزويلا مشيا
على الاقدام مشوا لمده اسابيع محمد حتى
يصلوا الى هذه البقعه من الارض الامريكيه
الذين يعتقدون بانها ستكون ملاذهم الاخير
هربا من اوضاع امنيه واوضاع معيشيه صعبه
للغايه هناك في فنزويلا السلطات المحليه
تتحدث عن عشرات الالاف اكثر من
50,000 استقبلتهم خلال اقل من اسبوع وهو
ما يفيض بشكل كبير عن قدرتهم الاستيعابيه
هناك منظمات في المجتمع المدني تساعد
السلطات المحليه في ايواء هؤلا لاء
اللاجئين وتسريع معاملاتهم وتوثيق حالاتهم
ومن ثم ايضا هناك منظمات مجتمع مدني
تستقبلهم وتوفر لهم مسكنا الحكومه
الامريكيه او السلطات المحليه بعد ان يقدم
هذا اللاج الذي مشى على الاقدام لمده
اسابيع يقدم طلب اللجوء تتركه في في سبيله
لا توفر له سكنا منظمات المجتمع المدني هي
من يحاول توفير قدر الامكان ملاذا او مسكن
او ماوى لهؤلاء اللاجئين حتى وصول موعد
محاكمتهم هنا الازمه في هذه المنطقه من
الولايات المتحده هي ازمه قدره واستيعاب
محمد لكنها تنعكس بلا بكل تاكيد هناك في
واشنطن ازمه سياسيه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين الجمهوريين يطالبون
باجراءات اكثر صرامه تجاه هؤلاء
والديمقراطيون يعتبرون ان هذه حاله
انسانيه يجب التعاطي معها على هذا الاساس
وابعادها عن التقاذف السياسي الموجود هناك
في واشنطن كان هناك قانون قر او امر
تنفيذي اصدره الرئيس الامريكي في شهر مايو
الماضي يامر هؤلاء بان يقدموا طلبات
مواعيد لتقديم طلبات اللجوء على المنافذ
الحدوديه الرسميه دون العبور بشكل غير
شرعي الى الداخل الامريكي وان هذا العبور
بشكل غير شرعي سيؤثر سلبا على طلبات
اللجوء لكن هناك ايضا استيعاب لدى الاداره
الامريكيه والى حتى السلطات المحليه من ان
ا هؤلاء هم من الفقراء من معدومي وسائل
والدخل قد لا يكون لديهم القدره على
الوصول الى هذه التعليمات والارشادات محمد
شكرا لك احمد هزيم من الحدود الامريكيه
المكسيكيه سنعود الى قضيه طالبي اللجوء في
فقره المتابعه بعد قليل ولكن هذه المره
لنرصد
سياق قمه لتسع دول اوروبيه مطله على البحر
الابيض المتوسط هدفها توحيد المواقف حيال
هذا الملف
[موسيقى]
شدد الرئيس السنغالي ماكي سال على ان جميع
الصراعات التي تشهدها البلدان الافريقيه
تتم برعايه ودعم وتمويل خارجي واعتبر سال
في لقاء خاص ضمن برنامج المقابله مع علي
الظفيري ان التدخلات الخارجيه تعمدت عرقله
جهود الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايكواس
الراميه لحل الازمات داخل
القاره
ان جميع الصراعات في القاره تتم برعايه
خارجيه انها صراعات ذات تداعيات خارجيه
ولها تمويل خارجي وهذا ما يقلل من تاثير
الاتحاد الافريقي خاصه انه اذا كان الامر
يتعلق باتخاذ اجراء صارم حيث يجب التوجه
الى مجلس الامن التابع للامم المتحده وفي
كثير من الاحيان يتم استخدام حق النقض
الامر الذي يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
تجميد قرارات متخذه
كان يفترض ان تساعد في ايجاد حل لو نفذت
لا نقفل ايضا ايادي بعض القوى وبالتالي
ستفهمون لماذا يعتقد الناس ان اطراف
الصراع المختلفه سواء في السودان او في
ليبيا او في جميع البلدان التي تشهدوا
انقلابات يجب ان يكونوا مدعومين من قبل
بعض البلدان ولهذا السبب فان الاتحاد
الافريقيه او ايكواس الذين كانا فعالين
للغايه في حل المشكلات سابقا جرى تحييده
ما بفعل هذا التدخل الخارجي في القاره
الافريقيه وهذا هو الواقع المرير الذي
ناسف
له وردا على سؤال بشان امكانيه لجوء
مجموعه اكواس الى الخيار العسكري لمواجهه
الانقلاب في النيجر اكد الرئيس السنغالي
ان هذا الخيار ليس مستبعدا في حال فشل
الجهود دبلوماسيه داعيا الجيش في النيجر
الى التنحي عن السلطه من اجل تفادي
سيناريو التدخل
العسكري نعم بالطبع هذا هو الموقف الاخير
لا كواس وبالتالي هذا هو الموقف الوحيد
السار المفعول ما لم تتراجع عنه ايكواس
لكن علينا ان نتفاهم بهذا الشان لم تقل
اكواس انها ستستخدم القوه على الفور
لاجبار الجيش على التنازل هذا هو الاجراء
الاخير وفي حال فشلت جميع المساعد
دبلوماسيه الجاريه فليس من المستبعد
اللجوء الى هذا الخيار الذي استخدمته
الجماعه مرارا في السابق لقد فعلنا ذلك
مؤخرا في عام
2017 في حاله جامبيا وقبلها في بلدان اخرى
في غينيا بيساو وسيراليون وفي ليبيريا اذا
ليس جديدا ان تدافع ايكواس عن استقرار
المؤسسات او تدافع عن الديمقراطيه في بلد
ما لاستعاده النظام ومساعده السكان على
الخروج من المازق وفيما يتعلق بالنيجر
هناك الكثير من الضجيج بشان هذا الموضوع
وكنت شخصيا اتمنى ان يستمع الجيش الى صوت
العقل ويتعاون مع اكواس من اجل التوصل الى
حل والحل هو ان يتنحوا عن السلطه وعندئذ
لن نحتاج الى تدخل
عسكري وننوه الى ان اللقاء مع الرئيس
السنغالي ماكسال سيبث كاملا ضمن برنامج
المقابله يوم الاحد الساعه العاشره وخم
دقائق مساء بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه يشهد الفضاء الالكتروني حربا بين
روسيا والغرب خصوصا خلال الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وتحاول روسيا عبر فرق الكترونيه
التصدي للهجمات الاعلاميه التي تتعرض لها
واستعمال منصات متعدده للدفاع عن سياستها
في
الحرب جبهه حرب اخرى تاخذها روسيا تترقب
ترصد وتواجه يغيب فيها السلاح التقليدي
والغلبه لمن يتقن لعبه المفاتيح على
المشغلات
الالكترونيه المهمه هنا لجيش الكتروني
يعرف بالجبهه الشعبيه مهمته رصد الاخبار
التي يصفها بالزائر عن الحرب وتتبع
مصادرها مجموعتنا تتكون من 25000 شخص وهم
موزعون في اماكن مختلفه وباع متنوعه
ومهمتنا الاساسيه هي ملاحقه الاخبار
الزائفه والفيديوهات غير الصحيحه ومحاوله
ايقافها في حرب الفضاء الالكتروني لا تريد
روسيا ان تغرد بعيدا عن منصات يتقن
منافسها اللعب فيها ولم تعد تعتمد على
الاعلام
التقليدي تدخل موسكو من باب لعبه عالم
الدبابه مثلا لتعيد تقديم روايه الك
عن الحرب في اوكرانيا فالحرب على مساحه
هذه اللعبه هي حرب على النازيه وتعيد
امجاد النصر السوفيتي على المانيا
النازيه تريد روسيا اصال رؤيتها حتى الى
الاطفال تدخل عالم لعبه الماين كرافت
وتمجد انجازاتها بل وتذهب بعيدا لاعاده
رسم انتصارات لها في المعارك الحاليه
باوكرانيا
روبلوكس فلاي كورب وارد ورفير هي جزء من
منصات وصلت الدعايه الروسيه بعد الفضاء
الافتراضي تحاول روسيا اقتحام كل المجالات
الالكترونيه للوصول الى شرائح
اوسع من الصعب اللعب في ملعب انت لا
تستطيع الدخول اليه لذلك نتجه الان الى
الشرق والى اماكن اخرى لنشر الرؤيه
الروسيه للحرب وهناك نتائج جيده واقبال
على سماع رؤيتنا قد تستحضر موسكو دعايتها
خلال الحقبه السوفيتيه كانت تقليديه فخسرت
المعركه امام الغرب اما اليوم فلا تريد
موسكو ان تتاخر كما تاخر من قبلها الاتحاد
السوفيتي الذي لم يبقى منه الا
اثره تدفع موسكو بترسانه الاعلاميه في زمن
الحرب على اوكرانيا سعيا منها لكسب الحرب
على كل الجبهات ولا تريد ان تخسرها في
الفضاء الاعلامي والالكتروني نوردين غير
الجزيره موسكو
[موسيقى]
وسط حاله من الاستياء ازاء الشلل الاوروبي
في التعامل مع ملف طالبي الوجو استضافت
مالطا قبل ساعات قمه لقاده تسع دول
متوسطيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي هدفها توحيد
المواقف تضم قمه مد ت كما توضح الخريطه
ايطاليا فرنسا كرواتيا قبرس اسبانيا
واليونان والبرتغال وسلوفينيا
بالاضافه الى الدوله المضيفه مالطا
الواقعه بين سواحل ايطاليا وشمال افريقيا
يجمع البحر المتوسط بين ثلاث قارات ويشهد
تدفقا لطالبي اللجوء من ثلاث مسارات
اكثرها ازدحاما الطريق المركزي من شمال
افريقيا نحو اوروبا وهو مسار يشهد ازمه
انسانيه كبرى منذ عام
2014 كان المسار الشرقي هو الاهم عندما
بدا الملايين من طالبي اللجوء الفرينه من
تداعيات الحروب والصعوبات الاقتصاديه
باتخاذ طريق الهجره الى اوروبا وبعد ويعد
المسار الغربي اهم طريق يسلكه طالبو
اللجوء للوصول الى اسبانيا بالخصوص وحتى
عام
2018 كان هذا الممر هو الاكثر شيوعا
للذهاب نحو اوروبا وفي ظل سياسات واجراءات
لمكافحه الهجره عمد طالبو اللجوء
والقائمون والقائمون على رحلات الهجره الى
تغيير المسارات مع مرور الوقت النقاش
الاوروبي بشان ملف طالبي اللجوء يتزامن
هذه المره مع ارقام صادمه اعلنتها اليوم
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله بالقول ان
البحر المتوسط بات مقبره للاطفال وان عدد
طالبي الوجوه الذين قضوا او فقدوا خلال
عبورهم هذا البحر في صيف
2023 ازداد ثلاث مرات مقارنه بالفتره
نفسها من العام
الماضي فقد سجل غرق ما لا يقل عن 990 شخصا
بينهم اطفال في المنطقه الوسطى بين البحر
المتوسط بين يونيو حزيران واغسطس اب من
العام الحالي ومنذ يناير كانون الثاني
الماضي توفي ما لا يقل عن
20089 طفلا خلال عبور البحر بحسب ما افاد
منسق اليونيسف في ايطاليا خلال مؤتمر صحفي
في روميا يوم
امس ويوم الخميس قالت مفوضيه الامم
المتحده الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين ان اكثر
من 2500 مهاجر قدوا او فقدوا اثناء
محاولتهم عبور البحر المتوسط الى اوروبا
منذ مطلع العام الحالي اما بالنسبه لبلدان
المغادره فبين مطلع العام الحالي الى
اغسطس اب حاول اكثر من 100000 طالب لجوء
عبور المتوسط من تونس و 45 الفا من ليبيا
وتقول مديره مكتب المفوضيه ان الرحله من
غرب او شرق افريقيا الى ليبيا ونقاط
الانطلاق على الساحل تظل من اخطر الرحلات
في العالم تنضم الينا الان من روما
الدكتوره رومينا كراتشي الاكاديميه
المتخصصه في شؤون الهجره واللجوء اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدتي هذه القمه في مالطا هل
تعتقد انها حققت ابرز
[موسيقى]
اهدافها افكار بالنسبه الى هذه القمه حيث
ان هذه القمه وبكل تاكيد كانت مهمه
بالنسبه الى البلدان المعنيه ونحن نتحدث
عن فرنسا واليونان وايطاليا وكرواتيا
ومالطا وقبرص والبرتغال وسلوفينيا
واسبانيا بكل تاكيد هي قمه مهمه لانها
لحظه لنفكر وندرس الواقع ولكن فكره ان
التركيز في هذه القمه كان على مشاكل
الهجره هذه الفكره برايي ليست مناسبه بشكل
كامل لماذا لان الاجتماع ايضا تطرق الى
مسائل اخرى عدا تلك المساله وهي مسائل
مهمه
لبلدان المتوسط لبلدان البحر المتوسط
نتحدث عن مسائل استراتيجيه بالنسبه الى
هذه البلدان على سبيل المثال ارساء
الاستقرار في منطقه حوض المتوسط والبحر
المتوسط وتامين الازدهار والاستقرار
لشعوب تلك البلدان اذا هذه هي الفكره
الاساسيه بالنسبه الى البلدان المعنيه
ويجب ان ينظر الى هذه الاجزاء الجنوبيه من
اوروبا على انها بلدان مزدهره وهذه القمه
سلطت الضوء على اهميه تطوير الشراكات بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي
والبلدان في الشرق الادنى هي نقطه في غايه
الاهميه بالنسبه الي لانها جزء من
استراتيجيه الاوروبيين والاستراتيجيه
الاوروبيه بشكل عام وقد ذكرت في هذه القمه
كجزء لحل مساله الهجره اذا هذه القمه لم
تتركز فقط على مساله الهجره بل تخطت هذه
المساله للحديث عن استجابات متعدده مرتبطه
على سبيل المثال بانعدام الغذاء العالمي
وهي
مس اسمحيلي دكتوره
جراتش هل هل هذه القمه يعني اسمحيلي
بالمقاطعه هل هذه القمه هي بديل عن الفشل
الاوروبي داخل الاتحاد في ايجاد صيغه
مشتركه فيما يتعلق
بالهجره هذه القمه كانت مهمه في حقيقه
الامر من اجل سبر السبل الجديده للتوافق
بشان مشكله الهجره ما الذي اعنيه بذلك
الفكره هي ان
هذه اللحظه هي لحظه سانحه لايطاليا فرنسا
والمانيا لكي تتحدث هذه البلدان بلغه
موحده بالنسبه الى موضوع الهجره
ولتحديد نقاط التقاء ونقاط تعاون بين
البلدان لدينا اعلان ادلى به الرئيس
الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون بالاضافه الى
رئيسه مجلس الوزراء بلوني قالا انهما
يعملان على حل مشترك لمساله الهجره في
المتوسط هذه نقطه في غايه الاهميه بالنسبه
الى ايطاليا غ وغايه الاهميه بالنسبه لنا
ايضا شكرا لك الدكتوره رومينا كراتشي
معذره على هذه المقاطعه بهذا نصل الى
نهايه الحصد في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]